good morning good afternoon and good
evening to all our participants my name
is Hamid khwaja I'm the principal
scientist for kavars and today we are
going to talk about NGS quality DNA and
RNA extraction from ffpe tissues using
our true extracted DNA extraction so
formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded a 58
issues is the most common method of
solid tissue preservation for clinical
and diagnostic be circles it was
primarily developed for use by the
technologists and clinical pathologist
because tissue morphologies maintained
after preservation cars on the room
temperature storage with over a billion
FFP that [ __ ] out rebellion worldwide
it's an excellent resource for new
genomic insight using energy activated
however since the technique was not
intended for use or molecular analysis
the innate reaction methods from a 38
issues has been highly variable and time
consuming or anti sincerely was looking
at the workflow of traditionally use of
extraction methods it's quite complex in
somewhat convoluted like the first stop
looking at the diffusion this passive it
depends on the use of our Shore
gynecologist island or materials such as
such a salt and mineral oil which always
leave them there of water or insoluble
from running off organic solvents or
oils on the office or this position
these methods are not efficient issue
rehydration steps involved for London
cavities in Commission Stephin several
alcohol water mixture tissue disruption
is often than carried out using laser
organizers or probe sonicator side as a
result of the inefficient after removal
organic solvents and oils on the tissues
the tissue is not rehydrated efficiently
it requires therefore requiring up to 72
hours of digestion with Proteus k
efficient reversal of the cross lips is
also affected by the subpar paraffin
removal in tissue rehydration DNA
purification from ffpe tissues is then
carried out using reagents not optimized
for use with ffpe tissue so the current
effort p nucleic acid extraction
techniques are quite limited by several
variables what is the protocol
complexity which involves utilization
and addition of many different reagents
prolonged incubation periods to obtain
changes and such they also require
dangerous organic solvents the use of
dangerous organic solvents and of course
the per month incubation periods for
various Regents adds quite a bit of time
to the process the yield the DNA yields
tend to be very poor with very low
reproducibility and the quality of the
DNA is not as good so there's a critical
need for new methods to accommodate the
sensitivity and quality requirements of
NGS based analysis platforms I using
call kavars using kavars adapted focused
acoustics we have taken a unique
approach to paraffin removal tissue
rehydration in extraction of nucleic
acids from ffpe tissue samples so in the
next few slides i'm going to describe
what khobar cfa is and also describe the
workflow of our troops activist PA DNA
extraction as well as the shows from
share some internal and externally
generated data kavars adaptor focused
acoustics is based on highly developed
technologies such as
therapeutic ultrasound as an example
lithotripsy which is used which in which
high-frequency acoustics is used to
break kidney stones and diagnostic
ultrasound for diagnostic imaging Kivar
cfa is a combination of these two
technologies but it's optimized for
biomolecule processing the technology is
a cavitation based driven process so
cavitation occurs when when acoustic
waves travel through a liquid medium the
dissolved gases the pressure waves
caused by the acoustics confidence all
gases to come out of solution as
microscopic air bubbles when these air
bubbles collapse fluids rush back in to
fill that void and these generate
extreme shear forces with Kivar saving
technology were not only able to control
the the cavitation for but also control
the shear forces just looking at some of
the differences between kavars
technology and traditional sauna caters
the technologies are vastly different so
then acoustic parameters that rustic
spectrum is also different looking at
the frequency traditional fornicators to
operate within 50 to 60 kilohertz well
with an audible range requiring hearing
protection from the sound kumar's
technology it operates at the between
point five and one megahertz are the
same as used by diagnostic imaging in
terms of the wavelength the traditional
sauna caters generate 10 to 15
centimeter wavelengths whereas kavars
technology operates within one to three
millimeter wavelengths which is well
within the usable range of the small of
vessels used to process your samples
looking at some of the attributes of the
kavars adaptive focused acoustics we use
a third wheel design transducer that
generates acoustic waves and focus
geometrically focuses them within your
sample to the size of this focal point
is about one millimeter in diameter and
a
the size of a grain of rice it's an
absolutely non-contact method of
delivery of energy and controlling the
energy so the acoustic energy is
optimized during each sample processing
and the temperature remains constant so
it's an isothermal method of processing
your samples so the using eye doctor
focused acoustics first for ffpe are
they could be examples it's a active
method of delivering several critical
steps during the process it's an AFA
beast method of the present the D
paralyzation fabs tissue rehydration
tissue homogenize ation and digestion
and nucleic acid release and we also
have ffpe tissue optimized nucleic acid
purification looking at the work flow of
the truth shortcut it is as simple as
123 you you'd be paralyzed and rehydrate
simultaneously using a reverse AFA and
then purify your samples using optimized
purification columns which then gives
you ng s quality DNA for analysis I just
want to quickly show a video of how
quickly we didn't d paraffin eyes and
rehydrate tissue using the kavars
adaptive focused acoustics done could
you play the video please
so these are in the video very rapidly
acoustics dislodged and removed the
paraffin from the tissue as you contain
the chart below within a matter of less
than a minute we're getting one micron
sized emulsion of the paraffin which in
which then remains alert during the
processing of the samples for DNA
extraction just looking at an experiment
which was carried out to check the
efficiency of paraffin removal from
tissue as you can see by the left corner
that's untreated tissue section FFP
tissue section the middle section is a
tissue section that was processed than
the paraffin removed you think are using
kavars AFA the right height panel slide
image shows one WR tissue section in
which the paraffin was removed using
xylene a diffusion based method and as
you can see there's quite a bit of
paraffin remaining over during the
during the passive passive diffusion
based removal looking at the options
that are available with the truths
tracked in terms of the DNA extraction
option allows you to share and extract
the DNA at the same at the same time so
you can adjust and select the size range
that's that's necessary for your library
Club it doesn't require transfer step in
the DNA extraction yields are quite high
option B offers you a larger fragment
extraction and it's recommended for
other genomic applications such as pcr
and microarray you can also extract the
largest possible fragments from ffpe
tissues using option C and these the
fragment size will depend on the quality
of the started tissue blocks but in our
hands and our lives we've been
able to very consistently get fragments
as high as 8 KB with option C there are
several quality metrics that are used
for assessing the quality of DNA that's
extracted from ffpe issues quite a few
people use the double-stranded DNA oh
then this is assessed usually using a
qubit fluorescence-based concentration
determination there are also qpcr based
amplification assays there's also pcr
qpcr based application as is such as
total amplifier both DNA yield and also
the best method is using sequencing in
depth of coverage to assess quality
looking at some data of comparison
between the two commercially available
kits for FFP DNA extraction compared to
to extract as you can see all three
options generate much higher yield as
compared to a kids from promega and
collagen we typically see a two to
three-fold increase in double-stranded
DNA yield looking at amplifier both DNA
yield we see that that is also a much
higher with all three options as
compared to the collagen kit in this
since these are done typically with
monitoring housekeeping genes they have
been used quite a bit for estimating the
quality of double-stranded DNA for
library path so in-house we carried out
a comparison using all three different
metrics comparing to extract extracted
DNA from ffpe vs chi and chi up so we
used kidney and units FFP tissues as
well as matched fresh-frozen tissues
obtained from CH TN and philadelphia
they were we had ten sections from each
block odd number sections from each
blocks for
kya kya and even number sections or
processes in Qaeda to extract DNA yield
and quality were measured using cubed
and we carried that whole genome two
times 100 base pair made pair library
sequencing on a loom on an alumina hi-c
2500 looking at the double-stranded
yield we see that it's much higher with
the kavars technology as stated it's
usually two to three-fold a greater with
both tissue types looking at the
sequencing coverage this is in this
slide you see a whole genome coverage of
the kavars FFP extracted samples
fresh-frozen DNA from fresh frozen
tissue and compared to the college and
FFP as you can see it there is the the
coverage is much higher with the
provirus NFP extracted samples looking
at this a little bit closely at some of
the chromosomes you can see that the
kavars technology offers much better and
much matched in matching the fresh
frozen coverage as compared to the
college's looking at some of the
chromosomes more closely looking at
homes of 16 for example as you can see
that the coverage with the collagen to
attract the sample this quite long as
compared to the kavars looking at
chromosome 17 it's very similar in that
the Kawara has much better coverage and
similar to fresh frozen tissue as
compared to collagen looking at
chromosome 19 which is the most gene
rich chromosome you can clearly see the
difference in coverage Kawara stephanie
has much better coverage and it looks
quite similar to that DNA that has been
extracted from fresh frozen tissue
sequence coverage uniformity is also a
much higher with kavars technology as
you can see in matches very civil is
it's quite similar to fresh frozen
tissue as compared to the collagen x
the DNA there was a recent publication
and blood from dana farber in which they
used the kavars to extract for their DNA
extraction from ffp tissue also at the
2014 AACR which was just a few weeks ago
dana farber also presented a poster
comparing the kavars to extract kneeled
and NGS quality to the traditional
methods the to extract the kid is also
automation friendly it the samples are
processed in SBS format plates the
samples are to the bar coded and
paraffin removal to DNA fragmentation is
all carried out in the same shoot
without transfer the DNA is ready for a
GS library for preparation and half a
date and you can process patches are
samples from eight to 96 samples but we
do have a to extract RNA track secured
and development it's a similar active
person removal and tissue rehydration as
the dnak looking at some of the data
that we have developed in-house you can
see the differences between the samples
between the two techniques a covert or
target qubit analysis for tested on just
two different kidney blocks show
dramatic increase in yield with kavars
technology but looking at rt-pcr which
is a viable result we see a two hundred
percent improvement over colleges
looking at other tissue samples such as
the prostate and breast tissue we also
see in improvement in yield but more
importantly we see a greater
reproducibility between the samples with
the kavars technology so the tube the
two shaft is immediately it contains a
highly efficient is a base paraffin
removal which allows for robust
ization of departmentalization and it
doesn't utilize the hazardous organic
solvent this leads to a complete tissue
rehydration which enables complete
ponies k digestion and results in
maximal DNA yield and quality for NGS so
which allows you to have a uniform
genome coverage I got across the DNA
from your samples so one of the takeaway
notes the most important takeaway notes
from this seminar is that the inequality
is only as good as the depressurization
technology you're using thank you very
much for for attending and we can take
any questions that you might have at
this time thank you for any for
additional information please or
questions please feel free to contact us
about ffpe at kovar sigcomm thank you
again and these are forward to your
questions so how did I have a first
question for you so does it matter which
Christ Madonna which provide mr. month
you use for is getn extraction no not at
all the two sharp kid has been developed
and optimized for use with all the
kavars platforms such as the m-series
f-series e-series and early serious
instruments and so how sick are fictions
that you're working with mounted tissue
sections or Scrolls can be as thick as
25 microns we are we can also work with
course which are about 1.2 biopsy cores
of up to 1.2 millimeters in diameter and
so you can get one question is with
coeds great twice you're not going into
small DNA diagrams when you are tracking
it you can get large anything on that
yes so you have three options as I
mentioned earlier there are three
options for the extraction size range
you can get library ready
if you're let's say for example doing an
alumina thought you could use option a
and get extract and fragmented DNA to
200 base pairs and if you're doing three
hundred base pairs and so on the sizes
are selectable so absolutely you have
control over the size range that you're
extracting so another question so could
you describe it it another device under
consumables that you're using processor
inches walk through the consumables is
the kavars to extract kit which contains
all the reagents necessary for the
extraction of DNA from ffpe as well as
for the purification in terms of the
instrument that you need for processing
you need one of the kavars instruments
such as the m.s c or ally serious
instruments and so thanks the parking is
a mystified can you kind of go into
today somehow the DNA extracts and dry
cider right so so once the powerful is
emulsified this typically generates
particles of about my crowd in size and
at this point is alert so when you have
a very good and efficient removal of
paraffin and your tissue is hydrated did
it allows for a much more efficient
digestion of your tissue matrix using
proteinase k which can which then allows
for a very efficient release of DNA from
your effort from your tissue samples and
so we have a lot of questions what is
the hardest some parts that you try wit
partied the hardest samples that we have
tried have been of course it really
depends on the tissue type i mean we've
tried quite a few tissue type samples
and everyone knows that tissue types
have different lea nails I believe
prostate tissue has been one of the
difficult ones that we've worked with
but compared to other kids the yields
have been much higher so we've been very
happy with its / for
across a variety of tissue types that
we've tested it has n at customer sites
and to be to another question that comes
often is easy to minimum required sample
size a minimum size the wood sample
requirement I think what I've seen in
the field has been the minimum thickness
of a section that we've seen mounted on
sliders been about five microns tissue
sections and that seemed to have worked
and I think the the sickness or the
amount or the slide number of flights
that you need to use to extract will
certainly depend on your downstream
application in terms of how much yield
you require for your sequencing
micro-ray or PCR applications so
sometimes you might have to process
multiple slides to get enough of a yield
depending on the thickness in the
quality of your sample so another
question is with the minimal minimal
edition volume so the presidio yeah the
minimum elution volume as we have stated
in the kids is about fifty microliters
but we have had people try also lower
volumes as low as about thirty five
microliters so it is possible but it
really depends on your application on
what your requirement are for it for
concentration and yield and so other
question around for the parking removal
so do the pre there so side of the
genomic DNA yes I mean we all know that
paraffin the fixed end formalin-fixed
DNA is going to be damaged to an extent
so you're not going to get fabulous as
large as you would from fresh frozen
tissue but in terms of what we've seen
based on our sequencing results and
based on the data that was also
presented by dana farber as their
sequencing we're getting very good
quality DNA for for library prep an idea
and so we have questions are positive of
how long does it take from
or a sign DMX yeah so the process takes
about less than three hours from from
sample to DNA but most of that time is
for incubation times so the hands-on
time is literally less than 10 minutes
and sometimes the mall the other time
periods are used for incubation for porn
is K and reversing up the crosslands and
so we're to have lots of questions over
the champ option option a B and C so how
you control the side of your finance
with deductions well Kivar cafa is the
gold standard that's used for sharing
DNA for next-gen sequencing so we're
very versed on we're very well
experienced on how to share DNA to the
right size range for four different
library perhaps and platforms and what
it was option a we can actually control
the sizes so we can share and extract at
the same time for whatever library size
range you need some 200 300 150
depending on your library needs and if
you need larger fragments that can also
be accomplished using option B or C so
other questions with Chum tissue types
so do you have to change your protocol
depending of additional not at all we've
we've actually optimized this kit by
testing it on a variety of ffp tissue
types so it's already optimized you do
not need to change the protocol we
consider it as a universal protocol for
of FFP tissue types so what I mean how
do we ask what is the footprint of the
equipment needed some civic gotta do it
depends on the instrument that you have
the m-series instrument is a very small
footprint it's about the size of a small
PCR machine it sits on the desktop that
it comes with everything included
including a built-in pelletier chiller
and a computer the S instrument is a
little bit larger about the size of a
bioanalyzer and the e instruments is
about the size of a tabletop centrifuge
half the size of a tabletop centrifuge
so all eyes from its can sit on a bench
and it doesn't require much lab space
and so we have questions can you go back
on the sequencing data and just because
you went a little sass can you just
under coverage on Unicom co-writers you
have a slide so I had question with
which slides in particular okay so well
as the question just you can go we r
existing so this trace is actually a
trace of the whole genome sequencing on
top you can see chromosome 1 through 22
in chromosome X and Y it's just a tracer
in showing the coverage with a baseline
of pad for both kyochon kumar's and FFP
frozen tissues so as you can see fresh
frozen tissue in kavars have a majority
of the reads are over 10 x coverage as
we look at the next slide which is
basically a graphical representation of
the percentage of coverage for all those
chromosomes from 10 to 22 you can see
that kavars has consistently higher
coverage than colleges and if you look
at the coverage and compare it with
fresh frozen tissue it is closely
matching the coverage percentage for all
those chromosomes to match frozen tissue
okay I'm come back on different options
of a BNC so are all the options
available is a second kit yes all the
options are available in the same pit as
the protocol is very simple to follow
you just follow the protocol for the
different options depending on your
desired size range and what the answer
is the protocol I thought the protocol
is available on our website so you can
download the protocol and take a look at
it in advance and so what would be the
maximum incubation time for protein easy
digestion the maximum four days k will
be about 24 hours is that really the
on the thickness of your tissue if
you're dealing with biopsy cores of
let's say one point two millimeters and
about four millimeters wide long that
will require a long program for this k
digestion to release and maximize the
yield of DNA and so did you try to laser
microbicide tissue we have not tried
laser capture microdissection because
because that requires that requires
removal of paraffin first before laser
capture but there are other
microdissection tools and systems in
which you my friend i SAT with paraffin
and were certain that that will work
with our technology and we're actually
going to collaborate with one company
that will for sure that analysis so okay
so I need I mean we cover most of the
questions some of the business that we
didn't answer we follow up with you the
webinar would be available on demand on
the website so I mean you can watch it
offline later yes thank you again for
attending a Girl mentioned the arrow be
available as demand and the questions we
unfortunately did not get to we will
contact you directly with the answer
thank you very much for attending and we
look forward to hearing from you